salut à tous et jean pierre foucault et
vous êtes dans brut
[Musique]
soit disant qu'ils avaient même s'il
n'est pas drôle soi disant qu' à madame
ci s'adresse qu'aux jeunes soit disant
cavada qui fait de l'humour pour les
ados
[Musique]
alors je sais pas s'ils sont toujours
six jeunes parce que j'ai été élu
l'humoriste préféré des jeunes ya au
moins huit ans donc c'est à dire que
ceux qui m'ont élu à l'époque il devait
avoir 14 15 ans maintenant ils en ont
bien 25 et je sais pas s'il faudrait
quand même faire une petite réélection
koala sûr je suis pas sûr de garder ce
titre là je les ai toujours dit le jeune
public je trouve que c'est parmi les
parmi les publics les plus difficiles à
convaincre c'est des gens qui ont accès
à tous à internet à la nouvelle
technologie à la vod a snapshot à
l'instar voilà aujourd'hui j'essaie de
parler d'autre chose mais aucun problème
pour ceux qui me considère encore dans
la case jeune j'espère y être longtemps
[Musique]
nous on n'est pas des hommes politiques
les humoristes les acteurs pour moi on
doit transmettre du fun on doit pas
transmettre de l' angoisse ou surtout
pas de la leçon moi j'veux pas là pour
dire mais attention vous triez bien vos
poubelles parce que les gens qui
m'aiment pas et même ceux qui m'aiment
ils vont dire mais pour qui se prend on
a pas besoin de tes conseils on est
maman on a notre papa tout le monde nous
a élevés a pas de problème par contre de
manière fun c'est bien d'arriver à
sensibiliser les gens pour moi la vraie
richesse c'est d'être avec des gens
qu'on tiff
c'est vraiment moi je depuis que je
gagne des sous je l'utilisé tous et sous
là pour faire en sorte que tous les gens
qui sont avec moi que ce soit ma famille
mes amis
les gens que j'aime bien mes petits
frères kif je veux que tout le monde qui
fait ce que la vie elle est tellement
courte j'ai vu tellement de gens
s'étouffer avec leur argent mourir super
riches
j'ai l'impression que ça sert à rien moi
ce que je veux c'est mourir super
pauvres et avoir fait qui fait tout le
monde
évidemment que il faut absolument pas
faire ça moi j'ai jamais été accusé de
plagiat et vous pouvez vérifier tous mes
spectacles de fond en comble j'ai tout
écrit moi-même
alors après les gens peuvent dire c'est
drôle ou c'est pas drôle mais au moins
je sais que c'est pour moi directement
ça s'adresse pas à quelqu'un d'autre
maintenant ceci étant dit parfois c'est
un peu facile de s'acharner sur
quelqu'un parfois il ya des cibles qui
sont un petit peu facile sans citer
personne parce qu'on n'est pas là pour
faire du name dropping parfois moi j'ai
été heurté qu'on s'acharne complètement
sur des gens en mode
ils ont zéro talent c'est que des
voleurs pourri quand on sait que ces
gens là ont fait des carrières entière
et ont inspiré beaucoup de gens moi
effectivement de voir qu'il ya
effectivement des similitudes dans des
sketches ben ça me ça m'interpelle mais
ça ne lève pas l'admiration que j'ai
pour ces gens et ça n'enlèvera jamais